on sert la bière je suis venu pour vous
parler d'un sujet qui j'espère va tous
vous intéressé puisqu'il s'agit des
vacances des congés du tourisme en
général bref d'une situation
véritablement traumatisant par les temps
qui courent tenez prenez l'exemple de
paulette merval est marcel merkès eh
bien ils sont allés passer une partie de
leurs vacances
woodstock chez les hippies histoire de
prendre un bain de foule dans une foule
qui ne prend plus jamais de bain depuis
longtemps à votre droite paulette merval
et à votre gauche marcel merkès
croyez moi c'est pas demain
tu veux
oui
il
l'écouté merci voulait tenir bâle et
bercy marcel merkès wiimote
c'est merveilleux c'est bien de chez
nous et bien écoutez maintenant toutes
les petites filles et tous les petits
garçons gens parmi nous ce soir à
provins dans la patrie d'un père lui dit
viens on rangera le plus représenté ma
charmante amy d'un lead dalida qui elle
est allée passer ces petites vacances
sur la côte d'azur vous semble-t-il
d'ailleurs la foule des petits des
petits baigneurs et des petites
baigneuses bien de chez nous ne l'absolu
ment pas gêné puisqu'il paraît ma chère
valide que lorsque vous arrivez sur le
sable vous vous mettiez à chanter et un
certain niveau vous aviez toute la plage
pour vous tout seul c'est merveilleux
c'est magnifique en l'écoutant les côtes
d'écouté maintenant nous faire un très
grand plaisir en nous chantant à tous
mes amis et à toutes les petites amies
un très grand succès ce qui a eu un
énorme succès nous écoutons
les urnes il est triste et les journées
mu de données par i télé que l'ombre et
les toits mais
il sait que donner comme une ombre et
dont les sondés sont sans fil est tombée
des voix